départ proche pour le norway paquebot
france belgium siècle leur est l'invité
du journal rentrée sociale grève à la
sncf du 22 au 24 au semaine d'action de
la cgt à partir du 3 septembre
cyclisme jo ou tel que convaincu de
dopage pendant le tour de france il
avait pris les anabolisants
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je suis
désolé de devoir commencer à nouveau par
les catastrophes mais celle de l'inde
est absolument d'affreuses 30000 morts
tel est peut-être le nombre de victimes
après la rupture du barrage de ma fille
nous vous avons montré hier les
premières images nous donnait une idée
de ce qui s'était passé derrière moi
l'image d'un jeune indien littéralement
cloué contre un mur par la masse d'eau
qui déferlaient et qu'il a écrasé les
nouvelles images qui nous parviennent
montre à quel point la région de leur
vie a été touché c'est à cause de la
rupture de ce barrage que la ville de
mort vie et les 17 villages qui
l'entourent ont été complètement rasée
quatre mètres de boue recouvre la ville
un hôpital a été entièrement détruit
avec ses 200 malades en un instant par
la masse d'eau et de boue déferlante
aujourd'hui encore on ne sait rien du
nombre des victimes si les autorités
indiennes font état de 1000 morts
les journaux parlent eux de 30000 les
secours s'organisent tant bien que mal
carlo peluche orange venu du ciel cette
fois complique considérablement la tâche
des sauveteurs
les sauveteurs qui ont assisté à des
scènes atroces des corps écrasés contre
les murs en mêlée dans les lianes et les
débris il n'y a plus d'eau potable et
les autorités craignent des épidémies
ce soir encore aucune information sur
les causes de cette catastrophe n'a
filtré de la commission d' enquête
on ne peut pas encore déterminée avec
certitude le nombre de morts dans la
course du fastnet plus de 20 voiliers
pris dans la tempête inattendu et
violente dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi ont fait naufrage en mer
d'irlande dans chacun des voiliers il y
avait plusieurs navigateurs pour le
moment on a repêché 17 navigateurs
moyenne le nombre des mipim sera
probablement plus élevé on a dit que la
météo britannique n'avait pas prévenu
des organisateurs de l'épreuve en fait
organisateurs et concurrents étaient bel
et bien prévenu que le temps se
détériore vrai et que la tempête menace
et les responsables de la météo anglaise
se sont fermement défendu d'avoir en
quoi que ce soit minimisé l'importance
du coup de vent qui a surpris les
concurrents du fastnet dans la mer
d'irlande
quand on sait à quel point les anglais
sont attachés aux chances de la mer et à
leur île
on ne voit pas pourquoi leur météo
serait moins bonne ou plus défaillante
que celle les autres salons personne ne
peut prévoir avec l soudaineté va se
déclencher une tempête et encore moins
d'intensité exact qu'elle atteindra il
importe d'ailleurs de préciser que les
plus gros bateaux engagés ont souffert
du mauvais temps ont subi des avaries
mais ne se sont jamais trouvés en
difficulté au point d'envisager une
évacuation
il reste que l'édition 79 du fastnet la
cinquième et dernière régate de
l'admiral's cup
le fastt 79 restera dans l'histoire de
la course au large comme synonyme de
drame de la mer le bilan si tant est
qu'on puisse déjà d'établir avec
certitude serait de 19 morts dont 15 qui
étaient engagés dans le fastnet plus de
20 bateaux auraient coulé ou en réhab
ont été abandonnées et on est
aujourd'hui encore sans nouvelles d'une
centaine de personnes alors cela dit car
il faut bien donner les résultats c'est
l'australie qui a remporté l'épreuve de
la défausse cap véritable championnat du
monde de la course au large et dont le
fastnet était l'une des quatre épreuves
eric loizeau que nous connaissons bien
car vous avez commenté pour nous la
transat en double vous participiez au
fastnet vous barrier le plus gros gâteau
français alors quelles conditions de
temps réel avez vous rencontré les
conditions de tentes est très mauvaise
pour pour la saison il y avait environ
60 noeuds de vent et
et la mère était grosse donc c'est des
conditions très mauvaises et la grosse
tempête la météo vous avait prévenus ou
non car il ya controverse
c'est très simple on savait qu'il y
allait avoir du mauvais temps seulement
on ne pouvait pas dire si sale est aussi
terrible que ça a été il y avait donc du
mauvais temps d'annoncer mais pas une
tempête effroyable pensez vous qu'il
leur était possible d'annoncer la
tempête non c'est absolument impossible
parce que vous savez c'est des
dépressions qui passe plus ou moins haut
on peut pas déterminer exactement nos
trajectoires et en plus de ça on peut
pas déterminer s'ils vont se creuser
beaucoup ou un peu moins hélas ces
produits normés mans
eric majeau comment ce qu il qu'il y ait
eu tellement de victimes si vous voulez
en général cette course ne se comptent
pas par gros temps parce que les
conditions de temps en atlantique
pendant l'été en général sont assez sont
assez faibles et c'est ce qui s'est
passé d'ailleurs pendant les deux années
des années précédentes
et effectivement il y à beaucoup de
concurrents qui ne sont pas armés pour
résister aux très gros temps comme on en
compte comme on l'a rencontré là c'est
une des raisons principales à mon avis
on a dit que certains bateaux était trop
petit pour participer à une telle course
à mon avis la taille des bateaux n'est
pas assez ce n'est pas le problème ce
qui se passe c'est qu'il y a des bateaux
qui sont plus ou moins qu'on sait plus
ou moins qu'un construit et de manière
plus ou moins fragile on peut avoir un
petit bateau solide qui résistera dans
du très très mauvais temps sans aucun
problème par contre un petit bateau même
un moyen bateau mal construit une
construits de manière à suffisant se
cassera et pourra couler je ne parle pas
évidemment de vous eric loizeau mais je
me suis laissé dire et j'ai lu que ceux
qui participaient à l'épreuve du fastnet
étaient en général des amateurs éclairés
peut-être mais désormais terre il ya
toute une gamme de gens emportés les
professionnels qui naviguent 100% d'une
heure leur temps et puis des amateurs
qui navigue un mois dans l'année
c'est ça le problème que peut-on faire à
votre avis c'est ma dernière question
pour éviter une telle hécatombe est à
mon avis on peut pas limiter le nombre
des concurrents
on ne peut pas interdire aux gens de
courir moi mon avis il faut plutôt
essayer d'éclairer les gens sur ce qui
peut se passer lors dire voilà vous
pouvez très bien courir dans deux ans le
fastnet
il pourrait y avoir le même la même
tempête que quelques la fois précédent
donc non embarquées pas c'est n'importe
quoi
90 les placer devant leurs
responsabilités ou bien d'en souligner
les mercis wavre le norway n'est
toujours pas parti tôt ce matin
d'importantes forces de police sont
évacués vers cluses françois 1er celle
qui commande l'accès à la mer du nord
ouest
évacuation sans incident majeur et très
rapide
à la suite de ce dégagement la
préfecture de la seine maritime a
communiqué les pouvoirs publics
comprennent et partagent les sentiments
de la population du havre au moment où à
s'éloigner un navire qui était à juste
titre l'orgueil de notre marine
marchande mais il ne saurait admettre qu
un grave préjudice soit porté à la
réputation et à l'avenir d'un très
grands ports français par des actions
dont l'origine politique est évidente
les responsables de l'ordre public
continue le texte que je vous cite ont
voulu respecter ce qui pouvait
apparaître comme la manifestation
symbolique d'une légitime émotion mais
elles ont le devoir de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour permettre
conformément à toutes les traditions
maritimes un bateau étranger de quitter
sans entrave
av sur un plan général elles ont dans
leur mission de garantir les conditions
d'exploitation normal du port tous les
marins ingénieurs techniciens et
ouvriers savent d'ailleurs qu'ils
seraient les premières victimes d'une
paralysie du port
d'autre part les équipages deux
remorqueurs de la compagnie des abeilles
ont confirmé qu'il refusait de servir le
paquebot pour l'aider à sortir en pleine
mer le bâtiment reste donc pour
l'instant au quai de l'oubli pour
essayer de voir où en sont les choses
aujourd'hui nous allons dans un instant
no rendre aux chantiers navals de brême
en allemagne puis nous interviendrons
l'armateur norvégien kloster après nous
aurons la réaction de monsieur séguin
secrétaire-général de la cgt d'abord
donc le point noir philippe gassot ce
n'est pas bon signe depuis hier
après-midi le remorqueur abeille
provence a quitté son mouillage à la
proue de l'ex france il a regagné le
quai en attendant la suite des
événements c'est lui qui était destiné à
tirer le navire vers le large
accompagné de trois remorqueurs juste
je t'ai l'activité de ces petits bateaux
indispensables à l'exploitation d'un
grand port c'est pourtant poursuivie
normalement toute la journée les
bâtiments bloqués pendant l'occupation
de lécluse en effet allé comme si rien
ne s'était passé à travers le chenal que
doit emprunter le paquebot pour
rejoindre les champions prennent depuis
ce matin
le passage est toujours gardé par les
forces de l'ordre et les routes qui
mènent étroitement surveillés ce qui
semble exclure pour le moment
le remorquage de l'ex france il y à 48
heures les marins laissé entendre que le
travail ne se ferait pas sous la
protection de la police
combien de jours encore le paquebot va
t-il rester l'objet de l'indifférence
des abeilles rien ne permet de le savoir
pour le moment pas plus côté amateur que
côté syndicats on sait simplement que
l'action menée par les marins c'est
autre chose qu'une ouvert
non j insiste sur le fait que les marins
et les autres nageurs n'ont jamais été
en grève ils assurent ils ont toujours
assuré le trafic du port simplement
qu'ils ont pris la décision de ne pas
assister le france tant que des débuts
de négociations ne soient pas ne serait
pas effectué mais il n'ya pas grève des
marins quoi il risque d'avoir des
problèmes
alors c'est ça ils risquent
effectivement d'avoir des problèmes car
selon paraît-il le pen light in il leur
serait interdit s'ils ne sont pas en
grève de ne pas assister ils sont
obligés d'assister tous les navires la
colère des marins est motivée par
l'intervention de la police ce matin sur
les cuisses françois 1er
comme lors de la nuit précédente les
syndicalistes occupent la place et
s'apprête à passer la nuit dans les
voitures qui mobilise le pont levant et
l'ex france par la même occasion
mais cette nuit la menace pèse des
pouvoirs publics ne vont pas laisser la
naissance de caractère il a manqué du
port sd
les crs et les gardes mobiles arrivés
quelques minutes avant trois heures du
matin le prenez aucun risque de dizaines
de véhicules des centaines de policiers
en tenue de combat
une armada impressionnante ne laissant
aux manifestants une solution abandonnée
la place avec le sentiment que résister
ici était à thomas michaud alors
lentement les manifestants ont quitté
les lieux
les derniers partaient vers 15h50 non
sans promettre de poursuivre l'action
ailleurs le concert d'avertisseurs a été
le dernier slogan des manifestants
g
ils se sont retrouvés ce matin pour
défiler dans les rues gloire avant une
autre manifestation prévue à double nous
ne reviendrons pas sur notre décision de
refuser de servir france affirmé
aujourd'hui à 19 heures un délégué cgt
des officiers des remorqueurs du port du
havre
mais le responsable syndical a toutefois
ajouté que les officiers du remorquage
de la compagnie des abeilles ne
s'opposerait pas à l'intervention de
remorqueurs étrangers nous n'avons pas
at il dit le pouvoir de le faire
l'armateur koster savent donner la
préférence aux chantiers allemands de
brême pourrait faire effectuer le
travail de remise en état et de
transformation du france de mener droit
comment travailler que représentent ces
chantiers en vertu de quels atouts c'est
à eux qu'on a confié le travail
un reportage de michel meyer notre
correspondant permanent à un ami ces
images de manifestations date de trois
ans les ouvriers des chantiers de la mer
du nord craignent l avenir à brême
on ressentait de plein fouet la crise de
la construction navale
ici en effet la moitié de la population
active dépend de la construction
maritime
face à une concurrence internationale
impitoyable japonaise surtout les
allemands n'étaient plus compétitif
depuis après modernisation et
reconversion de 30000 emplois
ils ont retrouvé une place de choix sur
le marché mondial après run musculation
délais de livraison et coûts de
fabrication sont redevenus concurrentiel
cela malgré le fait que les clients
payants deutsche mark
l'une des monnaies les plus chères du
monde cette mutation a été possible
grâce au très souvent cité est néanmoins
très réel consensus social allemand
c'est donc dans ce port de brême que
devrait bientôt arriver le nord ouest
afin d'y être réparé pour 30 millions de
marques moins chères et en moins de
temps qu'ailleurs la paix sociale
rétabli à brême a aussi dit on ici
derrière la main bien sûr était un
facteur décisif du choix de même que
l'existence de la confrérie
d'autres disent la mafia que constituent
les riverains scandinaves et allemand de
la mer du nord et de la baltique
pouey reste bloquée au havre avez vous
l'intention de faire appel à des
remorqueurs étrangers par exemple
allemand
la dernière partie j'ai pas bien entendu
mais c'est clair que le bateau doit
sortait d un aussitôt que possible
et si la situation s'est développe que
ça ne peut pas se passer d'une façon
normale avec le bateau qui sont sur
place nous devons faire appel à des
remorqueurs étrangers c'est clair c'est
clair effectivement monsieur alors
parlons chiffres le norway sera
transformé en allemagne les prix
allemands
etait-il beaucoup plus bas que les prix
français alors que le mark allemand est
une monnaie bien plus forte que notre
français correct
rien de très grandes différences entre
le dj français et le 10 ans allemands
et ça concerne aussi le délai ce qui est
le plus important pour nous c'est le
dernier parce que nous voulons commencer
le 1er juin 1981 et le chantier naval en
allemand peut livrer le bateau plutôt
que le chantier naval français
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de différences
dans le temps monsieur cost est ici oui
c'est une idée mois et demi entre les
débits français allemand on habite au
havre monsieur que vous avez choisie et
les chantiers allemands avant même de
prendre contact avec des chantiers du
havre dans la mesure où vous êtes vous
monsieur claustré depuis longtemps un
client habituel des chantiers allemands
est-ce que c'est exact non c'est pas
vrai du tout nous avons joué avec des
cartes ouvertes tout le temps et
les chantiers français ont eu les mêmes
possibilités que les gentils allemande
pour nous donner des devis compatibles
autrement dit les chantiers allemands et
les chantiers français dans cette
affaire était en ce qui vous concerne
par rapport à vous sur un pied d'égalité
absolue ils sont sur la base exactement
la même monsieur allez vous prendre à
bord des marins français
allez-vous tenter de conserver dans une
large mesure dans une petite mesure
enfin allez vous tenter de conserver ou
bateau une image de marque française
où allez vous offrir une compensation
quelconque aux ouvriers du haj détection
elle était non mais le bateau et
registre est un art mais ge et l'équipe
va être constitué comme nous le faisons
avec tous les autres bateaux
monsieur deux dernières questions la
compensation
on a dit que vous donneriez une
compensation au havre sous forme de
commandes est ce exact
non c'est pas exact oui je connais très
bien ce qui s'est passé en france
je trouve que c'est tout ça est très
très triste
le rôle d'abel de sportifs et nous avons
beaucoup des sympathiques où les
travailleurs travaillant à ces les
chantiers navals en france mais ils
doivent comprendre qu'il ya aussi des
chantiers navals dans d'autres pays et
la situation pourrait aussi grave que
tout est qu'en france et pour nous il
fallait prendre une décision est ce un
échec
monsieur je vous remercie d'avoir bien
voulu vous déranger en revenant dans les
studios de la télévision norvégienne
à propos de cette affaire du norway
georges séguy aurait affirmé au cours
d'une conférence de presse cet après
midi que la cgt le site n'entend pas se
résigner à l'évasion d'un million
d'heures de travail à l'étranger la cgt
a écrit aux syndicats vers man fait des
ran et de norvège afin que s'exprime la
solidarité entre les travailleurs des
trois pays cela dit monsieur séguin a
surtout annoncé des actions pour faire
face à ce qu'il appelle l'offensive anti
sociale du gouvernement et du patronat
première action une grève de trois jours
des cheminots avant même la rentrée du
22 au 24 haute attention donc si vous
devez prendre atteint ces jours là
ensuite la cgt prend l'initiative d'une
semaine d'action du 3 au 7 septembre
dès le premier jour de réduire selon les
entreprises la centrale de la rue
lafayette organisera des journées de
formation et de recrutement
elle éditera cent mille affiches et
distribuer un tract tiré à 7 millions
d'exemplaires
cette semaine d'action sera ponctuée
d'arrêts de travail et culminera le 5
septembre à paris par un rassemblement
place de la république
la cgt contre attaque donc mais elle
fait cavalier seul cette semaine
d'action ne sera pas unitaire pourquoi
voici la réponse de geof
entre temps des contacts ont eu lieu
entre organisations syndicales et il
s'est avéré la suite de ces
conversations que les autres
organisations qui n'étaient pas dans
l'état d'esprit d'organiser aussi
promptement une riposte syndicale que si
j'étais juge indispensable sans attendre
longtemps après la rentrée
pourquoi nous avons été à prendre amené
à prendre notre initiative qui n'est pas
contradictoire avec les actions qui nous
l'espérons débloquera la situation et
permettra ultérieurement des initiatives
unités l'action de plus grande envergure
andré bergeron avait lui affirmé
clairement qu'il ne s'allierait pas la
cgt mais en ce qui concerne les
positions de ceux d'été où ils désaccord
andré bergeron répète toujours la même
chose il n'empêche que c'est beaucoup de
ces organisations participent à l'action
commune avec la cgt est ainsi qu'ancien
de la cfdt est bien pour le moment la
position que nous avons prises ne semble
pas correspondre à sa stratégie et il
nous faudra voir avec cette organisation
l'occasion de contacts ultérieurs dans
quelle mesure le position évoluera et
l'unité action sera redevenu possible
genre marché lui
affirmé récemment qu'il était prêt à
s'allier avec le diable partagez vous
cette vive
nous souhaitons à l'union la plus large
à condition que chacun notamment les
partis politiques respectent
l'indépendance syndicale et les
prérogatives
des syndicats ce qui concerne la
conduite l'action revoir des kpi nous
sommes très jaloux de ses prérogatives
et nous entendons tout le monde les
respecte of quatre jours avant la
conférence de presse que monsieur
françois mitterrand doit donner anglet
dans les pyrénées-atlantiques
monsieur georges marchais s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui au micro de radio monte
carlo sur l'union de la gauche c'est
françois mitterrand veut relancer
l'union a dit le secrétaire général du
parti communiste français
cela veut dire qu'une fois il l'a brisé
s'il ne l'avait pas fait la gauche
serait aujourd'hui au pouvoir monsieur
marché a par ailleurs réaffirmé au cours
de cette interview qu'ils étaient prêts
à s'unir avec le diable pour faire échec
à la politique
giscard bas fin de citation étrange et
ahmed ben bella vient de protester
auprès des autorités algériennes contre
les brimades policière dont il est
victime dit il est contre ces nouvelles
conditions de vie qui serait selon lui
une détention
déguisés c'est officiel les atrocités
attribuées à l'empereur bokassa 1er ont
été confirmée aujourd'hui par la
commission denquête composée de
magistrats africains le président de
cette commission et sur hyundai a ou
magistrats sénégalais a déclaré
aujourd'hui que la participation de
bokassa 1er au massacre d'une trentaine
d'enfants
en avril dernier des quasi certaine mais
ce dialogue a d'autre part cité des
exemples de répression atroce à bangui
l'hiver dernier
tels deux enfants abattus sous les yeux
de leurs parents membres de la croix
rouge
c'est lors du dernier sommet africain
rwanda que la commission d' enquête
avait été constitué bokassa 1er déjà
isolé avaient été volontairement oubliés
par monsieur giscard d'estaing qui
présidait la conférence
aujourd'hui donc le rapport officiel
annonce un chiffre de 100 morts en
majorité des enfants massacrés sur les
ordres de l'empereur lors des
manifestations de janvier dernier sans
autres enfants emprisonnés ont été tués
en avril
et cette fois-ci bokassa 1er aurait
lui-même c'est quasiment sûr participé
au massacre
ainsi donc cet ancien sergent de l'armée
française devenu empereur rejoint au
comble de l'horreur un autre boucher
sanguinaire
le président maréchal à vie idi amin
dada que l'on voit ici en sa compagnie
deux hommes qui aujourd'hui ne font plus
rire personne
les conclusions de ce rapport vont
encore un peu plus isolé l' empereur de
centrafrique qui risque d'être mis au
ban des accusés par les autres pays
africains
grave la france et l'europe peuvent
décider de mettre un terme à leur
assistance économique ce qui aurait pour
conséquence d'aggraver encore un peu
plus la situation intérieure du pays
déjà catastrophique d'encourager du même
coup les mouvements d'opposition
politique mais aussi peut-être
d'accélérer encore un peu plus la
répression monsieur n'diaye a encore
ajouté que les soldats y voit avait
participé en grand nombre au massacre de
banque georges joueurs te dis viens
d'avoir au téléphone le président dia
qui présidait la commission denquête et
qui explique comment des enfants ont été
arrêtées en masse et comment se sont
passées les massacres voici ce coup de
téléphone dans les transports et dans
les maisons
pendant que les parents étaient tous
travaillent dont une majorité d'enfants
qui ont été arrêtés et détenus à la
prison de kahrizak lignée d'un rapport
dont c'était
et
mais tuer torturer un paquet dans des
cellules et wat
le couvert de parce que l'heure a tapé
dessus sétif qui comparaît depuis voir
que la réalité décembre est ce qu'à
votre avis l'empereur bokassa 1er a
participé personnellement à ces
massacres alors que les
les prennent pas profité
pour les autres de la presse gay et si
sa présence à la saison a été si
aléatoire reprises au moins sa
participation directe certaine à 100%
mais cette participation était
quasi-certaine trop beau le dj rapport à
la suite de la publication de ce fameux
rapport de la mission constatations sur
le massacre de bangui on s'attend dans
les milieux informés que le gouvernement
français fasse connaître sa position
dans la matinée de demain par le web du
ministère de la coopération
la démission de monsieur andrew yang
soulève les passions aux états unis
l'ambassadeur américain le n ud désavoué
par son fidèle ami le président du milk
artères s'est trouvée acculé à la
démission pour avoir rencontré dans le
plus grand secret il ya quinze jours
l'observateur des palestiniens aux
nations unies monsieur terry d'ailleurs
de cette entrevue l'ambassadeur yang a
donné plusieurs versions pour les noirs
des états unis le départ de monsieur yan
qui a toujours pris leur défense est une
perte irremplaçable
de son côté la communauté israélite
américaine applaudi au départ les
délégués de leurs aînés car washington
s'était engagé à ne pas avoir de
contacts officiels avec les dirigeants
palestiniens de la lpo et en rencontrant
le terrain
l'ambassadeur yang a donc transgresser
ces pouvoirs
il est allé trop loin agissant contre
l'engagement pris par les états unis
c'est pour avoir rencontré cet homme
monsieur terzi observateurs des
palestiniens aux nations unies que
andrew young a été contraint de donner
sa démission
la première réaction de monsieur terzi
la surprise il s'agissait d'un simple
entretien chez l'ambassadeur du koweït
andrew young décontracté a justifié sa
rencontre avec l'observateur de l'ol
paie mon seul but a été d'ouvrir les
canaux de communication entre les gens
israéliens et palestiniens qui ne
peuvent parler entre eux l'ol paie a
soif de reconnaissance
israël a soif de sécurité cette
déclaration n'est pourtant un point
final à la carrière d'ambassadeur à
l'onu de monsieur jung le représentant
le plus populaire
l'amérique est connu il avait prêté
serment en 76 carter l'avait choisie car
aux élections présidentielles andrew
young délégué de géorgie à la chambre
des représentants lui avait apporté 16
millions de voix d'edouard américain
andrew umnp avait accepté le poste
d'ambassadeur à l'onu qu'à condition
qu'il puisse dire ce qu'il pensait il ne
s'en est pas privé les cubains une
influence positive en afrique il ya des
milliers les prisonniers politiques aux
états-unis ou en corse l'ayatollah
khomeini est un véritable st à 47 ans
andrew yang était pourtant considéré
comme un lien un trait d'union entre
noirs et blancs en amérique et dans le
monde
grâce à lui les etats-unis se sont
réconciliés avec une vingtaine de pays
du tiers monde comme ici le nigeria les
noirs voyait en lui non seulement un
homme de leurs couleurs qui défendaient
leur droit à la tribune de l'onu
mais surtout l'ancien compagnon
l'éminence grise de martin luther king
qui l'avait été en 1961 plus d'une fois
il se trouvait en porte à faux avec la
politique même de son gouvernement sur
l'afrique par exemple en déclarant le
régime d'afrique du sud il légal jimmy
carter lui a toujours pardonner mais
l'opinion américaine est trop sensible
au problème israélo arabe pour que le
président des états unis acceptent une
nouvelle fois de passer l'épongé
andrew young était donc contraint à la
démission mais ce que le grand perdant
georges courteline du limogeage de
monsieur yang ne va pas être le
président carter s'il très probablement
se séparant de monsieur young le
président carter a peut être perdu en
fait les prochaines élections car en
1976 le quartier en avait été élu que
grâce au vote des noirs et il faut bien
dire que monsieur une fois parti d'un
vote des noirs risque fort de s'envoler
alors mais sur le fond de la sphère
j'entends les contacts les contacts ont
eu lieu monsieur aulas a confirmé fort
crânement il a confirmé que les
personnages officiels américains avaient
eu deux sens propre chef des entretiens
avec une organisation l'ol paie que les
états unis ne reconnaissent pas
cela dit faut parler clair si monsieur
young a fait un grand pas vers les
palestiniens monsieur carter en avait
fait quelques petits de pas donc on
pouvait s'attendre que monsieur carter
et c'est une fois de plus de le couvrir
s'il l'a désavoué et bien c'est parce
qu' une majorité du congrès et une
majorité de la presse américaine
son pour l'alliance israélienne monsieur
carter a donc senti que il avait quelque
chose de trop fort en face de lui la cdc
un peu humiliant pour lui et les
critiques ne manquent pas contre lui de
par le monde c'est monsieur marché même
qui disait tout à l'heure en france que
le président jimmy carter s'est
déshonorée en ligne jean bouilhou
en fait personne n'est content même les
dirigeants israéliens restent méfiants
devant ces marches et contremarches du
côté nord américain ce que les
historiens pour andy en tout cas c'est
que malgré tout ce clair obscur c'est
tout de même sous l'administration de
carter que la position américaine
vis-à-vis des palestiniens a commencé
tout de même à bouger bien que les
incendies de forêts dans le midi se soit
calmé les autorités ont décidé de garder
avis positif d' alerte au moins jusqu'à
demain
cette mesure doit permettre de maintenir
dans la région à peu près 15 sans
complice militaires au cas où le feu
reprend plus job2day mais l'udc a pris
des stéroïdes anabolisants
au cours des dernières étapes de
montagne du tour de france à présent à
arnhem aux pays-bas
la contre-expertise des échantillons qui
furent prélevés après la dernière étape
du tour et qui a été effectuée au
laboratoire du professeur donne ikea
cologne a été positive zoetemelk
démoralisés par cette nouvelle a précisé
que son médecin personnel français qui
l'accompagnent depuis dix ans lui avait
administré un fortifiant au cours des
étapes dans les alpes
j'avais trop maigri auparavant at il dit
et c'était le même fortifiant que celui
que j'avais utilisé l'an dernier quoi
qu'il en soit zoetemelk a remis en
question sa participation au championnat
du monde chaude qui a lieu justement aux
pays bas le 26 août je ne prendrai le
départ at il dit que si je suis motivé à
100%
or j'en doute pour l'instant hotmail qui
est ici dans l'une des étapes clés de ce
tour une précision s'impose d'ordinaire
sur le tour les contrôles portaient sur
la détection des amphétamines cette
année pour la première fois les
contrôles ont été étendues aux
anabolisants
auparavant ces produits étaient
essentiellement utilisé par ceux qu'on
appelle les hommes forts les lutteurs
les haltérophiles mais certains coureurs
sachant donc que les amphétamines
étaient détectés se sont tournés vers
les corticoïdes et les stéroïdes
il s'agit ici de ces derniers les
anabolisants qui augmentent la masse
musculaire autres mais elle risque 10
minutes de pénalisation au classement
final du tour une amende
deux mille francs suisses et un mois de
suspension avec sursis quoi qu'il en
soit la décision prise il resterait
deuxième au classement final du tour une
dépêche qui m'a paru totalement
incroyable quand j'ai reçus ils étaient
16 à 43 des octuplés une napolitaine de
29 ans madame maladry a donné le jour à
8 enfants dans une maternité de naples
l'hôpital des incurables
on précisait de source médicale que la
mère se portaient bien et que les huit
bébés étaient prématurés nés au septième
mois de la grossesse
madame maratrail y avait déjà eu
précédemment
six enfants en un seul accouchement
quant aux ses actus plaide aujourd'hui
il y en a déjà un
hélas ce qui est mort voici maintenant
les chiffres gagnants de la loterie
m'bia du loto pardon excusez moi 36 42
20 15 47 35 et numéro complémentaire le
onze je répète 15 20 35 36 42 47 en
ordre croissant numéro complémentaire le
monde
la météo pour demain et bien le temps
sera médiocre me dit-on en toutes
régions pluies orageuses sur le nord-est
et l'est les alpes la provence et la
corse nuage abondant et plus
intermittentes dans l'ouest le sud-ouest
quelques éclaircies sur le languedoc
fort vent d'ouest à nord ouest près des
côtes de la manche et de l'atlantique
notre édition est terminée c'est hervé
claude qui vous donnera les dernières
informations sur tous les sujets que
nous avons traité maintenant aux
environs de 23 heures
n'oubliez pas demain antenne de midi
présenté par daniel bilalian
et si tel est toujours votre bon plaisir
nous nous retrouverons une fois encore
ici même à 20h bonsoir merci